[Musique]
je suis venu vous parler d'une prise de
conscience qui a changé ma vie je me
suis souvent demandé comment accompagner
au mieux les enfants en tant que maire
j'ai eu à coeur de considérer mes
enfants avec le plus de justesse et de
respect possible et en tant que
psychothérapeute
je faisais de mon mieux pour aider les
jeunes que je recevais dans leurs
difficultés sociales et familiales
tout semblait bien se passer mais
pourtant malgré ma bonne volonté je
sentais que quelque chose clochait
et puis un jour j'ai entendu parler des
écoles démocratique des écoles dans
lesquelles les jeunes décident eux-mêmes
de leur emploi du temps et où l'autorité
n'est plus détenu par certains adultes
mais devient la sphère est la
responsabilité de tous
je suis allé voir sur place et j'y ai
rencontré des jeunes enthousiastes bien
dans leurs baskets pour moi ça résonnait
comme une évidence
au delà des carcans et des peurs
habituel un environnement fait de
respect et de confiance peut permettre à
chacun de s'épanouir
alors je me suis demandé à ce moment là
qu'est ce que je peux faire avec ça est
ce que moi je me suis pas trompé et
est-ce que j'ai pas contribué sans m'en
rendre compte à conformer mais jeunes
patients aux attentes qui pesait sur eux
plutôt que d'interroger la légitimité de
ses attentes et avec mes propres enfants
qu'est ce que ça changerait si
j'acceptais de laisser encore évoluer ma
vision de l'éducation
j'ai voulu approfondir alors je me suis
lancé dans une série de recherches et
d'expériences pour creuser le sujet de
la place des enfants dans notre société
est ce que j'ai découvert est allé bien
au-delà de ce que j'aurais pu imaginer
en fait je me suis rendu compte que les
enfants
ne sont pas vus comme des personnes à
part entière et que ce constat édifiant
passe encore largement inaperçu les
enfants ne sont pas vus comme des
personnes tu ne crois pas tu exagères à
oui tu et à toi je vous présente la voix
de mes conditionnement et préjugés sur
l'enfance il se peut qu'elle intervienne
de temps en temps bon pour voir si
j'exagère on peut déjà se demander
qu'est ce qu'une personne est ce que
c'est simplement un être humain
dans ce cas c'est sûr que les enfants
sont perçues comme telles mais les
esclaves étaient aussi perçus comme des
êtres humains
non il ya autre chose qui entoure cette
notion de personne et qui renvoie
davantage au respect à la reconnaissance
qu'on lui accorde
prenons des exemples
imaginez qu'un employeur abuse de son
pouvoir hiérarchique pour mettre une
claque à un de ses employés qu'il ne
ferait pas ce qui lui demande sans même
lui laisser la possibilité de s'exprimer
ou bien un état qui imposerait un seul
programme culturel et un emploi du temps
normalisé pour tous ou encore un mari
qui choisiraient la coupe de cheveux de
sa femme et qui l'obligerait même
parfois à embrasser des personnes contre
son gré ça semble absurde et violent et
c'est pourtant la réalité une écrasante
majorité d'enfants aujourd'hui dans leur
famille à l'école dans la société
ils sont obligés d'obéir aux adultes
dont ils dépendent qui peuvent se
permettre de leur manquer de respect ils
ne disposent pas de leur corps et de
leur esprit comme il le souhaite
oui mais ce n'est pas comparable
ce sont des enfants c'est pas pareil
merci de ton intervention surtout
n'hésite pas ce sont des enfants c'est
pas pareil
ce sont pourtant des êtres humains alors
quelle différence
et bien déjà
ils ne sont pas autonomes à nous y voilà
déjà on peut se poser la question
comment est-ce qu'un ensemble devenir
autonome si on ne laisse pas la
possibilité de faire des choix et puis
surtout est ce que le manque d'autonomie
d'un enfant justifie combat vous son
intégrité physique ou psychique
si on reprend l'exemple de la coupe de
cheveux imposé ou de la bise forcé est
ce que le corps d'un enfant ne lui
appartient pas cette appropriation du
corps des enfants par les adultes
explique peut-être aussi le taux énorme
de violences sexuelles et physiques
qu'ils subissent une sorte de tabou au
sujet de la considération des enfants on
préfère souvent relativiser regarder
ailleurs
parce que la vérité n'est pas tout à
fait facile à voir en face les chiffres
d'avril dernier dans quelques mois donc
nous révèle qu'en france un enfant meurt
tous les cinq jours sous les coups de
ses parents ou de ses proches ah oui
quand même
un enfant pour viser 5 joue ça paraît
presque surréaliste
oui c'est terrible et pourtant c'est
notre réalité ici et maintenant
alors la question est comment se
responsabiliser individuellement et
collectivement
pour ma part j'ai choisi d'aller
interroger des représentations profonde
sur le sujet le mot enfant vient du
latin infa ce qui signifie qu'il n'a pas
la parole et voilà ce dont je me suis
rendu compte
les enfants sont en partie rendu
invisible
moi par exemple j'avais beau passer mon
temps auprès d'eux je ne les voyais pas
en tout cas pas vraiment je ne pouvait
les voir qu'à travers série de préjugés
dont j'avais hérité
tu dis que les enfants sont invisibles
mais pourtant on les voit partout on en
parle beaucoup dans la presse ou sein
des familles on en parle beaucoup mais
on leur laisse très peu la parole
surtout sur les sujets importants
pourtant les jeunes sont bien plus
capable que l'on croit d'avoir un point
de vue pertinent et notamment sur les
sujets qui les concernent en fait ils
sont doués comme vous et moi d'une
raison propre et d'un ressenti clair et
même si cette capacité à raisonner et à
ressentir est différente chez l'individu
de 2,10 ou 40 ans elles existent
néanmoins dans tous les cas et puis
l'histoire nous a montré que les adultes
n'avait pas toujours raison les parents
de copernic devait lui apprendre que la
terre était le centre de l'univers
on peut se tromper et on se trompe
toujours en fait puisque notre
compréhension du monde est en constante
évolution
dès lors pourquoi ne pas profiter
davantage du point de vue des jeunes qui
partagent notre vie et proposer nos avis
plutôt que
les imposer j'ajoute que cette
dévalorisation du point de vue des
enfants ne se manifeste pas toujours à
travers une violence visible par exemple
décrit ou une forme d'intimidation
la plupart du temps elle est masquée par
une sorte de fausse bienveillance c'est
tous ces moments où on va se dire qu'on
protège nos enfants alors qu'en réalité
on fait peser sur leurs épaules des
peurs qui nous appartiennent et si on
choisissait de faire vraiment confiance
à nos enfants et de les respecter autant
que n'importe qui ça donnerait quoi
c'est au moment où je me posais cette
question que j'ai entendu parler d'un
projet d'éco village qui est intégré
dans son fonctionnement
ce principe de respect de l'enfant à
personne ni une ni deux j'ai foncé et je
suis allée co créé cet éco village avec
25 autres personnes d'horizons très
divers
là bas chaque individu peut contribuer
peut participer comme ils le souhaitent
aux décisions de la vie collective et
occupe son temps comme il l'entend
certains enfants ont fait le choix
d'aller à l'école et d'autres pas ils
apprennent outreman à leur rythme
par exemple ma fille de 7 ans vient
d'apprendre à lire à sa manière en
parcourant avec nous encore et encore
ces livres favoris
là bas je peu exploré à fond toutes ces
idées sur les rapports adultes
enfin je me suis aperçu que on peut
transmettre sans imposer son point de
vue on discute beaucoup
on s'influence les uns les autres à
travers nos manières d'être et si je
fais il ya ne pas être dans la
domination
je ne suis pas pour autant des
missionnaires de mon rôle de parent bien
au contraire
je vais aussi à ne pas passer de la
domination à la soumission qui sont pour
moi les deux facettes d'une même pièce
devenir une sorte de parents esclaves ne
serait bon pour personne
et le respect commence par soi même
après pour être respecté dans la
relation je m'aperçois qu'il n'y a pas
besoin d'être violent en criant ou en
manipulant l'air de rien d'ailleurs
quand on y pense être obéi c'est
différent d'être respecté l'obéissance
c'est le fruit de la peur le respect
c'est le fruit de la reconnaissance de
l'autre
ce que j'observe c'est que quand il ya
une base de respect mutuel dans une
relation
on a simplement envie de prendre soin
des besoin les uns des autres sans même
avoir à se forcer pour ça par exemple
avec mes enfants je n'impose pas des
heures de coucher ils ont appris à se
connaître ils savent quand aller dormir
mais moi le soir j'ai souvent besoin de
temps pour moi je ne sens pas tellement
disponibles du coup on a trouvé un
arrangement
s'ils veulent que je les accompagne pour
le coucher il faut qu'ils me le demande
avant 22 heures sinon ils peuvent payer
mais ils s'engagent à être autonome pour
le boucher et à être vigilants bruit
c'est un arrangement qu'on a trouvées
ensemble on essaie de tenir compte des
besoins de chacun je me demande parfois
que donnerait une génération qui n'a pas
été conditionnés à obéir qu'à eu le
temps et l'espace d'apprendre à se
connaître en profondeur à ressentir à
réfléchir à développer un esprit
critique qui a pu apprendre aussi à le
communiqué en identifiant ses besoins et
en prenant en compte les besoins de
l'autre
tout ça m'a tellement passionné que j'en
ai écrit un livre qui s'intitule
qu'est-ce que l'âgisme
parce que quand on y parle
elle n'est pas si loin l'époque où ils
étaient collectivement admis que toute
une partie de la population était
inférieure aux autres parce que de sexe
féminin ou par ceux à la peau noire
alors si les mentalités ont largement
évolué aujourd'hui sur les sujets du
racisme du sexisme
peut-être qu'il est temps de se poser
collectivement cette question de
l'âgisme alors donné autant de droits
aux enfants qu'aux adultes faire peur on
peut sembler irréaliste
un peu comme si on prenait les enfants
pour 2010 adultes mais en fait il n'en
est rien il cette méprise est plus
qu'intéressante à décrypter en fait un
pic l'idée selon laquelle nous citoyens
bénéficiant de certains droits nous
pourrions considérer comme nos égos que
nous semblables alors non les enfants ne
sont pas en tout point semblable aux
adultes leur être en croissance
leur développement physique affectif et
cognitif particulier leur donne
spécificités mais cette spécificité ne
définit pas leur identité
de la même manière qu'une personne à la
peau noire n'est pas un noir ou une
personne porteuse d'un handicap
un handicapé en tout cas personnellement
quand j'ai pu toucher du doigt avec mes
propres enfants
ce que pouvait être une relation d
conditionné de préjugés hagist j'en ai
été ému aux larmes par delà les idées
préconçues sur ce qu'est un enfant ce
qu'est un parent ce que peut-être leur
rapport je les ai rencontrés pour de
vrai
dans leur singularité brut et sur ce
pont bâti entre nous ils ont aussi pu le
voir tel que je suis réellement et non
pas enfermé dans un rôle parce que
finalement il ne s'agit pas ici de
penser que les enfants peuvent dans une
certaine mesure être considérés comme
des personnes mais qu'ils sont des
personnes qui se trouvent simplement
être des enfants voire lettre au delà de
l'âge c'est le cadeau que je nous
souhaite à tous merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]